[Music]
come in every year around this time
McDonald's releases its McRib sandwich
and the McRib sandwich has a huge cult
following and well it was just revealed
they just announced that McDonald's has
decided to push back the McRib launch to
late December yeah yes yes my reaction
exactly this has this has a lot of
people who are anticipating the McRib
very very upset including one of our
writers here he is to discuss this
controversy mr. Deon Cole
Thank You Conan well I wrote a funny bit
on the McRib sandwich controversy but I
felt that it would be too stereotypical
for me to be black talking about the
magrib so I decided to have another
writer do the bit I wrote so here's
another one our writers Brian Kiley
thanks Conan McDonald's why did you all
drop the ball like that us black people
look forward to the McRib coming out
every year and to push back the date
just isn't fair but I noticed that white
folks got their shamrock shakes on time
didn't they where's the justice
McDonald's
and me being a strong militant dark
chocolate with a splash of caramel
righteous brother I will not tolerate
any unfairness including here at this
show hey Conan we're all the blacks at
this should be more of us working around
here and why isn't there any Hennessy
cavour CA in the green room
[Applause]
and lastly at this year's Christmas
party can they be more big-booty ladies
their can drop it like it's hot and
isn't afraid to let a brother like me
slap it up and flip it on the dance
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]